tenemos esto de aquí que es 3 por toda
esta expresión de aquí 5 x + 6 y luego
más toda esta expresión de aquí 7 x + 2
y todo eso por 4 y lo que te pido que
hagas en este momento es ponerle una
pausa al vídeo e intentar simplificar
esta expresión pero te doy una pista vas
a necesitar utilizar la propiedad
distributiva y combinar algunos términos
muy bien estoy suponiendo que ya lo
intentaste y ahora vamos a hacerlo
juntos como acabo de mencionar cuando
vemos el 3 y lo estamos multiplicando
por toda esta expresión
lo que queremos es distribuir ese 3
entonces voy a multiplicar 3 por 5x y
también voy a multiplicar 3 por 6 así es
que 3 por 5 x aquí tenemos 5x y queremos
multiplicarlo por 3 y nos va a quedar 15
x
y después 3 por 6
18 si es que acabamos de simplificar
esta expresión y es 15 x + 18 y ahora
vamos con esta otra parte aquí tengo
esta expresión larga que estamos
multiplicando por cuatro y no importa
que el 4 esté después de la expresión
larga de todas formas lo queremos
distribuir aunque entonces queremos
hacer 4 por 7 x y 4 por 2 4 por 7 x eso
es 28 x y 4 por 2 es 8 si es que ya casi
terminamos esta parte de nuestra
expresión se simplifica en 28 x + 8 y
ahora lo que podemos hacer es combinar
términos similares por aquí tenemos 15 x
y a eso le podemos sumar 28 x y bueno si
tengo 15 de alguna cosa
eso le sumo 28 de esa misma cosa
entonces vamos a tener 43 de esa cosa o
sea 43 x lo que hay nada más sume los
coeficientes y tenemos 43 x y después 18
más 8 es 26 26 y listo ya terminamos
tomamos esta expresión larga y la
simplificamos y para hacer eso
utilizamos la propiedad distributiva y
encontramos algunos términos similares y
los sumamos y nos quedó 43 x más 26